嘿，你聽過那種只花一點點錢，然後在社群媒體上爆紅，幾週內就賺大錢的故事嗎？我今天看到一個案例，讓我有點驚訝。
這種故事我聽過不少，但很多都是曇花一現，或是背後有大公司在操作。成本低、收入高，這模式能撐多久？到底是不是真的有這麼神奇？
這個案例的確滿有意思的。主角是一位23歲的年輕人叫Oskar Flodstrom。他居然是從Facebook Marketplace上找到一個免費的透明壓克力底座，然後把它改造成一個創意生活用品，而且兩週內就創造了15萬美元的營收。
等等，Facebook Marketplace？免費的？這也太出乎意料了吧。一般公司或人在想產品的時候，誰會先去二手平台找材料？這做法讓你詫異在哪？
我詫異就在這裡。通常我們會想著要投入多少研發、找什麼供應鏈、開發新材料，但Oskar是從現有資源裡找靈感。而且他一開始也沒想著要大賣，就是單純做一個「藥瓶造型」的邊桌，因為他公寓沒什麼錢裝飾。
好奇他是具體怎麼做到的？就一個藥瓶造型的邊桌？這有什麼特別的？
他撿到那個壓克力底座後，其實放了好幾個月都沒動。後來他花了大概120美元買了泡棉、油漆和紙張做標籤。最關鍵的是，他把整個創作過程拍成影片，然後發到社群媒體上，他用的帳號是Erik Oskr。
拍影片？所以是靠內容行銷？但這樣就能有15萬美元的營收？感覺有點難相信。
原文有提到，他之前也發過一些影片，甚至還賣掉過一個類似酪梨造型的椅子，大概賺了500美元。但這次的藥瓶邊桌很不一樣，他的影片在六月突然爆紅，甚至引起了一家叫NO LOGO的公司注意。
NO LOGO？這又是什麼公司？他們的介入有差嗎？
這家公司主要是協助創辦人或品牌製造產品，但他們自己沒有工廠。NO LOGO主動找上Oskar，幫他免費製作樣品，而且還幫他把藥瓶蓋的材質改良得更穩定，更重要的是，他們還幫Oskar架設了Shopify網站。
原來有專業的製造和銷售支援，難怪會起來。不過，光靠一個產品就這樣病毒式行銷，模式撐得久嗎？成本除了那120美元，還有其他的嗎？
其實剛開始也是有波折的。他的影片因為藥瓶標籤有「Adderall」字樣被Instagram的AI標記。他原本以為第一天能賣出10到15個，結果36小時後只賣了幾個。
嗯，這很真實，不是每個爆款都一開始就順利。那後來呢？怎麼會突然爆發？
後來他換了個方式。他拍了另一個影片，展示藥瓶邊桌作為洗衣籃的「不同用途」。結果這個影片在Instagram上創下了每小時一百萬次觀看、持續十小時的紀錄，這太驚人了，直接帶來了200個訂單。
換個用途就爆發？這點其實不容易做到，需要對產品有新的詮釋。所以最終就是這個社群傳播的力量，兩週就賣了15萬美元？
是的，就是社群媒體的力量。從這個案例來看，如果你是創業者或主管，我覺得可以學到幾點。首先，不要小看現有資源，二手市場、廢棄物都可能是創意的寶庫。
這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字和做法。但對一般上班族來說，這概念怎麼帶入工作或生活？難道我也要去找二手垃圾來改造嗎？
當然不是說要你真的去撿垃圾。而是像Oskar一樣，他其實一開始只是想解決自己「公寓沒錢裝飾」的問題。你可以想想看，你生活或工作中，有沒有什麼小困擾？那些困擾背後，會不會藏著解決問題的機會？
你的意思是，用創新的思維去解決身邊的問題？而不是一味追求高大上的解決方案？
怎麼說呢，就像Oskar，他從一個免費的底座出發，用低成本的材料去實現他的創意，然後透過社群媒體的力量去放大它。這好像也提醒了我們，有時候創新不一定需要高科技或大筆資金，關鍵在於洞察與社群行銷力。